I have never pulled off a prank before
when I was told I would be a part of
this episode with Sabrina and with the
amazing cast I was so excited to finally
pull off a prank I'm about to transform
into the klutz prank that I'm part of
unlock the prank is I get to go
undercover as a distant cousin of the
kids that are being babysat by all
regular real-life babysitter's that we
get to prank and let's go up the prick I
watched the first episode of walk the
prank and I was immediately hooked the
kids are so talented and the pranks are
so funny and so realistic I was like oh
my god walk the prank is so different
from any other set that I've been on
because it is a prank show and you are
dealing with little people who don't
know that they're being filmed I'm going
to be blondes with pink tips on my hair
ready to walk the prank cuz I am I play
I'm the older cousin and I suggest that
you note of curiosity we should go and
explore my uncle's archaeology lab
there's a mummy lying there with this
really cool amulet and then the whole
room suddenly starts to shake was the
total role reversal because in vendors
in babysitting I play the babysitter
this time on the troublemaker which is
really fun to be on either side of the
story I'm not very experienced with
pranks so I'm it's gonna be a good
learning experience for me I'm super
excited to to be able to embody a new
character and at the same time just get
the rush of pranking people that's the
best feeling in the world it's gonna be
pretty epic